welcome back to new rock stars this is
the boys underground where we chat about
about amazon's darkest horrific
superhero show you're going to fight me
i'll say live-action superhero show it's
close to bad what's another 17 years i'm
jessica clemens brought here today with
me
is let's start this way this time
brandon barry oh hello glad to be back
yes and then we have marina masters
yeah yeah you guys though we didn't
quite get there the real hero chasm was
watching butcher huey and soulja boy
beat the [ __ ] out of homelanders so
close it was i when i was watching the
show i was like
this is the hero yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was it was very satisfying to see
someone or uh three people be able to
like take him on a little bit and for
him to be on his heels a little i get
beat up he i just needed and honestly
it's it's so crazy how this was a kind
of medicine for me where i was like i
just needed a little bit yeah a little i
could taste it i didn't have to be
knocked down yeah like
you know he wasn't gonna get beat right
there yeah but like getting close was
nice that was nice i'm now like oh okay
i can keep watching yeah but let's let's
start with our recap so we can get
really into it yeah yeah okay so now
that homelander knows that soldier boy
is back the deep through his wife's
research discovers that soldier boy is
going after his old team payback uh and
the next closest target would be the tnt
twins housed in vermont a lovely
mid-century model
really nice
beautiful
great orgy house
homelander sends the deep to vermont to
report on whether or not soldier boy is
going to show up uh and the deep is into
it a little too into it here's something
i want to talk about real fast octopuses
octopodi uh they have you could say
octopodia because octopus uh is a greek
word you could say octopodia it's
totally fine for the plural of octopus
uh they have beaks yeah i was thinking
about that well i don't think he was
i think he was
doing the mouth but i also was like
because he kept saying like your arms
are so many and all right so you guys
getting grip
there is a beak but they don't have to
like close it yeah
but if they didn't really hurt yeah yeah
what if the octopus sneezes i don't know
uh so last week at cedar kamiko was in
the hospital with no powers one of venus
goons kidnapped kamiko from the hospital
and brings her to her warehouse holding
frenchie and sherry captive that was a
heavy scene uh i thought for sure
someone was gonna die there one well
someone i thought sherry was gonna die
oh and it was gonna be brutal i'm glad
she did it uh and kamiko did it uh
nina's henchman they were gonna kill can
we go in front of frenchie or kill
sherry he had to choose uh before the
henchman could pull the trigger can we
go broke free and killed everyone in the
room everyone but nina who escaped she's
out there somewhere uh frenchie took
sherry and camiko to a safe place and
fixed her up man it was brutal watching
camiko get punched
that was heavy heavy stuff she must have
i mean maybe she has a tiny bit of
residual because i was like shoot we did
i mean that was brutal that's what you
have surgery right here and then someone
punches it seven times so i'd be like
i'm dead piece of me was like it has to
be residual there has to be a little bit
of something but then also like i guess
if you had that power and you're getting
your ass kicked every day you probably
still have that feeling of adrenaline
so yeah as frenchie's healing her up uh
they have a heart to heart recognizing
their traumatic childhood is probably
the reason they're so violent uh but one
day they'd be able to overcome it and
this show is really about like
overcoming your childhood trauma for all
of our characters um soldier boy butcher
and huey arrive in vermont to kill the
tnt twins this is where we get a glimpse
of herogasm
louie and butcher injected themselves
with tempe compound and i must say it's
very convenient for huey to just uh
appear naked i know it actually worked
out perfect uh when soldier boy
confronted the tnt twins they blamed it
on black noir very easy to blame the man
yeah
uh however everyone knows noir doesn't
do things unless vaught tells him and we
knew vaughn was behind this long time
right soldier boy triggered again by
this russian song uh that keeps playing
we'll bring that up a little bit later
he begins to power up and explodes
blowing up the house and killing almost
everyone inside
victoria newman discloses to starlight
that she can make people's heads explode
so that everyone's on the cards are on
the table there
and she she's on starlight's side but
needs to use her instagram account to
goose her numbers as she says i also
love the little like secret i made your
nose bleed i i re-watched it her eyes
don't do anything but like yeah it was
like a nice little surprise uh but
sterling ain't having it she's tired of
being used as a pawn and tells victoria
to [ __ ] off blink fat uh yeah we're
gonna believe a lot of things we say
yeah uh mm and starlight have now teamed
up to stop soldier boy they're done with
the bloodshed they're gonna clean up the
mess clearly that doesn't go well when
soldier boy blows up the house uh and
starlight later and a heartfelt insta
live post announces that she quits
soulja boy is not the american hero we
should love and homelander is a [ __ ]
liar hashtag bot lied people died bot
lied people died baby
i gotta say true they really nailed the
tech overlays this episode yeah youtube
was perfect yeah the instagram thing was
perfect it's not hard people get it
right
we all are on the internet all the time
we know you're using a fake thing it was
perfect
black noir ripped his chip out and ran
now recognizing that soulja boy is back
we remember how shell-shocked he was in
nicaragua uh maeve is still missing no
way she's dead uh ashley is still
ripping out chunks of her hair i don't
know how she is i know
i think she's using v just to grow hair
uh an a train got payback on blue hawk
by turning him into a meat crayon and
dragging his face across the pavement
running just as fast as he can
holding onto one another uh and
ultimately has that heart attack that
his doctors have warned him about yeah
yes yes
you wanna do merch yeah hey but before
we get more into this episode be sure to
check out our awesome merch options over
at newrockstarsmerch.com we're currently
featuring two that's right two latest
obsession shirts our obi-wan kenobi
limited edition shirt called empire's
most wanted and our miss marvel inspired
shirt titled cosmic daydream both of
these shirts are limited a dish and
won't be available for long so check
them out along with all of our other
awesome merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com
we also want to remind you that new
rockstars is going to be live and in
person not on your computer screen
anymore uh we're going new rockstar is
going to be appearing live in austin
texas as part of the rtx austin 2022
podcast festival july 1st through july
3rd if you've ever wanted to see some of
your favorite new rockstars host in
person now's your chance jessica
clements is going to be there along with
tommy bechtold phillip molina uh eric
boss they'll all be there just click the
link in the description and use promo
code new rockstars that's all one word
for a discounted ticket price come on
out and check out the wildlife show we
put together it's going to be really fun
there's trivia there's things you can
win it's tons of fun we guarantee you'll
have a great time
and be sure to check out some of the
other awesome podcasts that will be at
rtx boston 2022 to save on your ticket
click the link in the description and
use promo code new rockstars we hope to
see you there
beautiful
and if i don't see you in austin texas
i'll see you in these miscible details
i'll see you i'll catch you in these
missable details today so something we
like to do here miserable details let's
get into it because there's so much in
this episode and i'll be i'll be honest
i hit all of them
we love pop culture call backs this
video of soups uh at the very beginning
of famous people singing imagined by
john lennon as an homage to the horror
that was imagined by celebs in 2020 when
we were just entering co-fit
in order of appearance we have the deep
pat nalswalt a train josh gad mila kunis
gymnastic kusher elizabeth banks kumail
nanjani aisha taylor uh rose brynn and
black noir who does not speak but holds
up
that's great i thought for sure roseburn
was like in the original she really
nailed the look of it yeah the like
sweater the turn of her head it was like
perfect yeah
i'm like yeah that joke's been
done but i think they were really nailed
it was very satisfying to me i was like
get them there were some good guests
i think they did also a good job because
keep it keep note it was so cringy and
none of these actors were in that
opinion
so these are the good ones
okay we know homelander is cuckoo for
coco puffs to the extent of talking to
himself in the mirror which is featured
in volume 9 issue 49 of the comics but
just like season 6 episode 2 issue 47
home letter states the only man in the
sky is me while referring to god and
kills a family of four in the comics so
we know he's insane it's just to what
extent right you know and i love that
they're taking these pieces from the
comics and they had a episode this
season already titled the only man no
yeah that's yeah and he said that line
he was like i'm god and he does that
exact line to the family and that uh
issue in the comics he takes a family of
four in a car flies through the sky
they're like yay whoo grease and then
he's like he's like i don't care what
happens to you guys and just drops the
car and they all died
very
horrible so it was interesting seeing
how he got really scared when vaught was
in trouble because he was like i'm
vaught like that's his weakness now is
this company
yeah yeah which i was like
huh yeah you're true
i don't like that mirror side of him
talking i mean especially when it was
like direct to screen and like looking
at us and that thing he says was like
when we were in the bathroom
i got you out of the bathroom or
whatever so it's like when he was a kid
this is a personality turned to shades
of what we saw on the moon yeah i was
like i think he has did from being
traumatized as a child
this personality fully takes over and he
cuts out the cancer of humanity that
lives inside of homelander which i've
never seen any humanity inside of
homelander
big big time trouble yeah
literally um but what you guys have all
been waiting for oh my god we've all
been waiting for it's the 70th
anniversary of herogasm allegedly
founded by soldier boy and liberty oh my
god i don't remember who liberty is it's
stormfront what a firecracker
when he says she's a firecracker and he
was just like who's gonna tell him who's
going to tell them
your orgasm is volume five of the comics
it's a six issue run uh and said comics
soups and villains must come together to
destroy a common enemy to the public
when in reality they have a massive orgy
called herogasm to just [ __ ] relax uh
this is where also soulja boy and
homelander have sex um i mean is it in
the right light absolutely not there's a
lot of troublesome sex things happening
in this and that issue um uh soldier
boys having sex with him in order to get
into the seven but he's not gonna get
into that yeah do you know how it works
uh you know how it works you know how it
works uh you know how the games play
yeah i mean that's a fascinating warning
we had as the show started uh and uh oh
yeah they're so funny yeah i hope all
those extras were treated kindly on set
it was pretty intense what i i i still
think it was not as intense as the first
episode but like nothing's a penis hole
nothing is the penis hole thought they
were going to go above the peanut i love
love sausage though i think love
sausages are so funny um also call me
but um well except for now that his dick
is like burnt
and dragged
[Laughter]
oh yeah
uh tommy and tessa make up the tnt twins
which do not appear in the comics okay
but they do have the power to launch
fireballs one's joining hands and
yelling tnt detonate
very um they're under twenty twins yeah
barry wonder twins uh what are they they
yell just wonder towards your knight
right they yell what's activated
my favorite part i'm not going to get
the wonder twins movie unfortunately
it got cancelled
but we got this we got this i was my
because i was so i was expecting it to
be so bad is that right then i kept
being like oh no they're gonna have sex
that's what i was worried about
oh god they're fighting and they grab
sex they definitely showed us like a
toilet can i mean that was pretty bad
well i thought and then i thought
something was gonna happen and i was
like that's bad yeah that didn't happen
yeah and i was like
a butthole compared to a penis hole i
think the penis still works yeah they
gave us consolation under that shot
yeah yeah also um going back to really
quick what you said about the extras i
noticed with the extras that they were
um
a lot of the lines were dubbed yeah they
were dubbed so i was like and i'll we'll
i'll get into it actually i'll actually
get into it with more of our missible
details because some of those lines
dubbed are very fun and by different
people from the show
the true icon
love sausage is back and healthier and
girthier than ever oh that very long
peen was
wrapped around mother milk's neck in
season two episode six and let me tell
you it's all a little too friendly
it was just swimming through everything
it didn't care it had yeah that's why he
was like get it off me yeah i've already
seen this before he's like you look
familiar yeah
i was like yeah you choked me out with
your dick my dude um and also here are
some other folks this is where
i was going and
i was going deep i was re-watching
rewinding to see the superheroes and i
think i'll do i can even post some more
on twitter uh that ones that we might
have missed but here are some of the
superheroes that are at hereorgasm uh we
first got we got termite
we know termites love them termite
wiping his juices
that was on funny poor mothers milked
this episode yeah no poor babies
actually really establishing his ocd
getting this more of the story behind
its creation his own trauma put in every
kind of i don't talk
every type of bodily fluid on it yeah
yeah um what could possibly be
invisalign so invisible ass was in um
the herogasm comic books invisilize is
basically susan storm right and um she's
invisible um and she is in like a
foursome with the fantastic four known
in the comics that's fantastico
so we could be seeing invisalize walking
around with the uh the vibrator in the
credits in imdb eagle the archers in
this episode i have been zooming in
trying to find out which one is eagle
the archer and i'm still looking for
langston kerman oh in the comics shahee
myth exclaims
on my hump um in which that line is
directly put in this episode it doesn't
say who says it but shaheem could be the
person
yeah
and also the voice of the man yelling
throwing ropes oh my god
which i'm never sorry i've never me
neither is that a thing
the term ropes roping oh okay yes is the
it's the act of uh completion for a
gentleman that's so weird
i mean
throw in
i get the look of it um the voice of the
manual throwing ropes is the showrunner
eric
that's so funny oh my god
he was probably like finally yeah this
is for me
and if you don't remember that scene um
it's when mother milk gets milked on
speaking of milk dawn the t-shirt mother
milk is wearing after changing from the
incident is the tnt smile time hour a
kid's show starring tama and tessie the
tnt twins um i love that at their orgy
they're like do you want our merch
there is so much to see also on the
walls of the orgy house of their like
what they used to be and it's kind of
like a sad like they have like cases of
like collectible items and stuff like
that i mean i don't know what the
baseball bat he broke out oh yeah oh i
should have like i mean you know it's
clear they collect like memorabilia
stuff like that 100 and that they do
shows because she was like you're you're
not gonna be at the mall yeah yeah yeah
this is without me um and lastly that
beautiful
perfectly executed fight scene took five
days to shoot really it took five days
of rehearsing researching and just
shooting and it makes sense because the
choreography is so close of four people
it's not like when stormfront was
getting jumped because this is like
they're not
it's like they're jumping but there's
he's also fighting back so that was
outside so it's like a lot oh yeah this
is closed space
100
uh so after those missible details let
me know of the ones clearly hair orgasm
is a very fun comic series very quick to
read go ahead and read it i will say
like amazon there should be trigger
warnings on it
there's a lot of uh dark stuff that
happens in the herogasm comic episode
run but for our big questions of the
episode
where the hell did black noir go where
did black noir on the run right that was
so funny when she was like thank you
just watching him getting sprayed with
blood if i worked there i'd be like
should i give this to someone i mean she
clearly did we saw an evidence oh yeah
she was like wow this is anyone who
works corporate knows uh you got to make
a problem not your problem yeah yeah
uh cya couple years seriously i turned
it in uh you sent an email cc everyone
you know it's like oh i just turned in
black noir's tracker yeah
i'm good thanks do we think that black
noir is by himself or do you think that
he might have ran to like the legend or
stand up oh i mean
yeah we know he has a closer
relationship with stan was there for him
uh in nicaragua maybe he also knows
where maeve is oh yeah
i still think he has a vendetta for
maeve which he rightfully does yeah she
put him in a coma put him in it yeah
right
now you know homelander called he's like
you're the only guy i can trust he knows
he doesn't want to be that like that's
not the guy and like knowing that
soldier boy is out there he's like he
knows that homelander can't stop him i
think and that's why he's like i'm not
sticking with homeland i gotta get out
of here yeah and no one needs to be able
to find me 100
i think probably a good i mean if he's
smart he would go get me to help him to
help his side even though he put her in
there like he might be like this makes
us even i get you out of here you put me
in a almond joy coma
now were because i uh my guess is that
she's in one of those traps superhero
boxes yeah 100
i also think as because again like you
said traumatic childhood experiences are
really big in this show i think they
really um
connect to those and keep going with
those and him getting his face like
blown off and being like i just want to
take off my mask and now being like well
now you can't yeah that triggering
moment probably came back to him of like
i worked with bot to send soulja boy
away now he's back in that moment yeah
yeah all i lost everything for this for
nothing and now he's going to kill me
and was like no and to know that he's
like act he's getting away with it like
he's like actively now he's gonna know
like oh he did kill the tnt twins yeah
and gunpowder's dead and all this is
happening like he's probably like i need
to get out yeah i need to get out i need
to i need to run um yeah i like him i
like um i also want more for black noir
because i know me too my mom will call
me and be like
oh i she does not like what's happening
with adrien
they train and she's like that's our
black character and i'm like well we
have black noir and she was like yeah
but what the hell
i mean i think there was a good reminder
this episode that a train
has his own past and has not
officially apologized like really they
made penance for it and it was very
interesting this episode when he would
confront him and he he now know now that
he's experienced
the suffering with his brother yeah he
what gives a legit i'm sorry and it you
know it still feels a little false
because he's not used to doing it he
still gets punched for it well deserved
but yeah he's not without his own
uh past that he needs to reconcile i
i'll be honest i was like someone hit
ashley but then i was also like ashley
is completely right she's like yeah you
like it happens to you and now you care
but you did it to everyone and she's
also a prisoner to all letters yes she
has decided to embrace this role and
makes it most of it yeah
uh but it's you know she's trapped and
there's almost that moment where she
almost breaks out with uh starlight
right and then she's like no yeah no
because i think she knows like even if
she teamed up with starlight she's going
to die yeah it's like you this world has
shown that the good side does not win
ever yeah she has the least choice in
all of this but when during her speech i
was like she writes she said
i was like she's right you ran through
people yeah and that's like even worse
like you ran through people
actually at least they're still so much
fun yeah i love ashley i love actors
that have
she's
fun
so great and i feel like that character
was going to be written off so quickly
yeah me too i literally thought she was
already dead
i was like isn't she already dead
i think the uh the boys
actors are phenomenal there is not one
single i can look at so many shows you
guys just because i'm in hollywood and
watching actors all the time that i'm
like i genuinely am taken out of this
role because this person is not acting
well but in the boys everyone so jensen
echols this season this episode
holy crap as soldier boy i'm getting
that like weird powerful like 80s white
man
yeah it's a boomer energy of like what
do you mean a man's a man doesn't carry
his voice i went around oh my god i
wanted a couple songs
okay what happens when you have only
girls
like damn oh my god okay speaking of
shenanigans that aren't true uh did they
try and die
okay
i mean we saw him so we see him lying on
the street we see we hear his heartbeat
go like start slowing down and then it
fades out and we don't it didn't give us
like a flatline because it wouldn't be a
flatline right but i think he's just
barely hanging on because he didn't like
do you know the thing that i actually do
when they go
yeah the death rattle yeah
so i think he's just i think we're my
prediction they're gonna find him barely
hanging on
and then he's gonna be super terrified
of running again because this was his
last time doing it or he tried to do it
and then they're gonna bring him back
and that will
be his turning point i know because he
almost had a turning point like he
apologized and got punched then he went
right back to killing yeah real quick
and so now he's gonna finally stick to
the side of like good side like he's he
goes like this constantly and now i
think he's going to just be like all
right i almost died
i'm on the side of good yeah true i then
your mom will be happy yeah we'll be
happy
i'm sure she's happy she was when i was
talking around the phone this morning
she was like oh i was so happy when you
got drugged across them yeah
to be fair to me
i cringe at so many scenes of like gore
but this one i was like yeah get him i
was like dragging him
i'm just glad
i was afraid when they stopped that you
would hear a little gurgle
he was still alive like
you know what my biggest fear was but he
was clearly gone by that point my
biggest fear was him stopping when he
stopped and we saw the dead body and i
heard police sirens
that was my biggest fear
i was
no i'm not having it today but i do not
think he's dead and i think with another
shot of compound v it can revive him a
little bit make him a little bit but i
do think he'll be like on the edge like
it'll be like do one more time see what
happens but i think i really want black
noir to run into him and i also want
black noir to be like
um him to talk to black noir and have a
heart to her and black noir be like you
know i'm black right
here
i'm not going to be a pushover to you
i'm going to be honest with you you're
being ridiculous right now um like
there's other matters going on in a
train you don't need to paralyze your
brother yeah
and it was kind of his fault i'll say it
i'll say it he should have never brought
blue hawk there oh god no yeah oh god a
train so i don't i don't think he's dead
but if he is dead i would say it would
make for good storytelling because he
had such a horrible arc but then finally
redeemed himself yeah
i mean if and if he's not dead this is
the last time you can give him a heart
attack okay yeah yeah yeah
you can't play this card anymore no more
heart attacks let him
work sewing oats on a field
like
like so and i was like i want him to be
like a farmer now i want him to like
literally leave yeah and be oh he just
like retired yeah yeah i need people or
do something without cameras following
you yeah that's your redemption i
understand that like being a celebrity
is so hard to be taken out of that
lifestyle because you're like i'm famous
but it's like a train come on you are
digging yourself a hole right and then
no one's gonna want to see you period
back yeah and that's when you're thrown
to the wolves okay uh why did bots sell
soulja boy to the russians do we talk
wait yeah
we interact kind of everything we figure
out every episode we learn a little bit
more about this story i mean it's got to
be
my theory is that like vaughn is just
controlling the world in a strange way
uh you know through their government
influence through their corporate
influence to their consumer influence
uh and i think like this was like maybe
a deal they made with the russians
because like they control the compound b
they obviously don't want russia to get
it especially in the 80s yeah and it's
the idea that like we'll give you
soldier boy you give us money we'll give
you soldier boy and you can try and
figure it out
uh but we're not going to give you
compound b right i agree with you you
know why i started on this because we
answered this question last week um and
i answered it the exact same way yeah
but this is it confirms what you said i
was like i answered it the exact same
way i was like they're definitely
working under the radar yeah but i also
think they're two-timing the russians i
don't think they're like actually
working with the russians i understand
i'm like we always we you know how
america does
there was a great homage here to you
know the uh
uh muhajin i said that wrong one oh i
thought your situation in afghanistan oh
my god we're like america and the 80s
yeah it was a proxy award it's the
soviet supported the muhajj and he was
like
he was like they were the good guys they
were like oh watch like i think it's
rambo two maybe at the end of rambo two
there's like a whole thing it's like
yeah yeah we support afghanistan you
know like we're on that side and like
reagan met with them and all everything
and then it's like yeah we and then 20
years later we're fighting them with the
weapons we get them yeah you know it's a
great little munch to that real american
history look it up folks
well you need to do the breakdowns that
are like
real life
um is is soldier boy really blacking out
because he said the first time he did it
he blacked out yeah when he said what
happened in midtown he said i blacked
out and 10 minutes later everyone was
dead i didn't mean to and then at the
party he said again i blacked out he's
like what happened yeah what happened oh
yeah you came to like what happened and
i hate that butcher didn't take put two
or two together and i mean you say you
killed everybody yeah i know like
butcher still kind of needs him i
do you think
we talked about this a little offline i
said that
he is going to be a problem if he can't
control his powers and i don't think he
can control his powers without being
triggered so his first step is learning
out of this cryogenic freezer in russia
is learning how to control his triggers
because
you mentioned how it's the same yeah so
this song that he heard we heard it uh
two episodes ago
one episode ago when he blew up on the
street and then it's the same song we
hear again at this yeah twice now i hear
orgasm it's called escape by mikhail
schufinski uh it came out in 1982 it's a
real song it's the same song in both
episodes
my question is is he really is this song
actually being played diegetically in
the room or is he hearing it in his head
is there like a signal going through the
the radio or something like that
because why would
you know in the first time we heard it
in the us it was maybe an area of new
york that had like russian immigrants or
something like that and here at hirogasm
there's love sausage who's maybe russian
or vaguely baltimore yeah i don't know
it's like why is this song being so much
a very specific very russian song okay
so i my only two arguments that i want
that i want what you're saying is true i
think i want it to be like that's his
key that's his wake-up call that's his
sleeper agent or
longing 100 whatever 100 i want that i
want that so bad like that is what i
want but the only two reasons is a so he
did blow up crimson countess without it
yeah so he could be triggered by the
song not to say he couldn't he could be
triggered by the song and also his
emotions overwhelming that could be two
things i completely see that i would
love that i'm also like
it seems i think you mentioned this
seems like a bad idea for the russians
to put a top song yeah if the record
created this trigger why use a russian
song because he's going to go off and
yeah he's going to go off you've got to
put an american song in you got to put a
new kids on the block song yeah yeah or
just one song that you have no one
listen because the song about them
the song came out in 1982
and he was captured in 1984. in 1982
he's killing killing innocents in
america uh so it's very of the time it
would make sense that the time he was
captured and being tested on he's
hearing this song maybe in the
laboratory or something yeah but if they
purposely implanted this song as a
trigger it's the wrong song to use
you want him to go off in america yeah
although is it because he's hearing it
everywhere in america in 2022. but i
also like that like they listen to this
song on repeat yeah yeah they're like oh
we got the
bullets in his mouth put on our favorite
it's not any other song i still think
about that footage of them just firing
an ak-47 into his mouth that like haunts
me that is so crazy to think that he's
feeling it but like surviving it yeah
it's just nuts i think he i think he
probably is being triggered just because
he's he is doing a phenomenal job acting
and he does look like out of control
yeah and when he
uh
exploded at the party and then when they
were like charge up care burster again
for um for homeland or he
took him a long time
you knew he was going to get out you're
like oh this is taking away yeah yeah
because like it because like he did the
first one involuntarily in i think and
then so then when he has to do it again
voluntarily because with crimson it was
just one right time and he really hates
crimson yeah yeah yeah so this time on
command he was like wait wait oh i have
to do this again oh
take too long also i can't wait for all
the jokes butcher's gonna use about not
finishing the next episode
use his voice you're better at accidents
than me
you killed my becca oh
okay oh couldn't get it up all sorts of
boy there you go i was in trouble
finishing the job
uh goop from the huey's ears what the
hell was it yeah very early when they're
in the hotel room with soldier boy and
hughie kind of notices a little goop
coming out of his ears i think he's
gonna od it was kind of blackish gray it
didn't look like blood and he was he he
doesn't go like oh blood he's like huh
doesn't butcher
huh i have a nose bleeding butcher had
like a nosebleed butcher also was like
puking a lot
i thought i attributed that to
like long explosive crimson's blood like
old mines like because
his own brain no i mean that makes way
more sense yeah because i was like i
thought he was just like ew i didn't get
all of it in my shower or whatever yeah
but but that makes women i mean there's
obviously going to be some long-term
effects yes temporary v that's still
experimental and regular v is bad enough
uh so yeah i i don't know what the hell
it's gonna be it's worse for it to be
coming from your brain right you don't
want anything coming out of the ear hole
because he's also for huey out of
everyone it's euphoric yeah so i'm like
oh he's just he's willing to give up his
relationship with starlight yeah or the
feeling of being powerful like that also
in that scene we gotta talk about the
oriental chat oh my gosh
what happened to the chops which is a
great nod to the chest sauce of
mcdonald's made famous again by rick and
morty
several things soldier boy says this
episode uh you know 40 years later not
so great the baby bjorns or whatever
the bill cosby america oh my god making
strong drinks oh my god not only is he
partying with bill cosby yeah he's
literally having sex at herogasm with
stormfront the nazi who i'm not
surprised she likes getting lasered to
the chest yeah so this makes exact sense
that she'd be doing something like this
he and it's the nods the writers are
doing such a good job of choosing which
nods to choose like which ones to do
yeah i also love the like the the food
came from vaught a burger yeah what a
burst poop he was eating a homie burger
which is hilarious so what was he taking
he said benny's what are the benny's
drugs
it's an upper like he says like we won
the war with this stuff like
they would give troops uh they
experimented on uh us soldiers they
still do uh with different drugs and
they amp them up on methamphetamines and
go yeah fight your worst
that's right
uh what is the fate of our very lovely
maeve well she's not dead there's no way
she's dead everyone and everyone and
everyone's mom my mom um are saying that
maeve is not dead it's not dead and i
don't think she's dead i don't think
she's dead either but like
when are we gonna find her could
homelander like really hurt her i guess
yeah he could he could just pick her up
and drop her because she doesn't right
well i think he didn't really he was
like actually hurt i don't when i say
this is because i don't care about his
feelings
oh there was one scene
last night i want to oh it's a
homelander and i said what the hell am i
doing i was like when i left
when he was like he wouldn't leave me i
was for a second i was like i think it
was where i was like oh and then i was
like what am i doing i know yeah i was
like get it together i mean i will say
during the mirror scene there when he
when the evil side of him mentions the
human manatee that he is like the human
that he still is he's like oh yeah this
was a he was a young boy who was not
raised properly yeah uh and mystery as a
kid he's dealing with his own trauma is
he a bad person now yes does he need to
recognize that yes
has the power gone to his head yes
but there is still a boy in there that
was mistreated and my fear now okay
he's he's let off the chain he sees he's
now has like the fear of like there are
people that can hurt me
now he's scared now yeah he's gonna
become the super villain my fear is that
he finds his son
gets his son out of there his son hates
him yeah right but if he could get his
son away his son has also been abandoned
by butcher his father yeah
so
his son is that kind of in the same
position now if he gets his son they can
kind of become this like
force
and it does remind me of amazon's other
dark superhero show invincible where
it's like the fear of not knowing where
homelander is yeah and he's kind of
afraid to come back but he will come
back stronger that's the big fear right
literally yeah i'm afraid he flew away
to antarctica
where he's like building a base up there
or something like that what if who
homelander flew to the moon or something
can you breathe in space i don't even
know yeah i think
he can do enough does he even need air
to breathe
i don't know i don't need the air i
love you
now for the
kills here we go all right very
satisfying this uh episode so when nina
is holding cherie kimako and serge
hostage kimiko kills nina's henchman
with the sharp end of a popsicle stick
which i thought was very cool she then
kills the other henchmen with a shard of
metal and she stabs him in the chest
exactly 17. that's so delicious ten more
times than he stepped or then he punched
her which i was like
soldier boy fire zaps the twins to death
at the herogasm party along with 10
other people and a train street drags
blue hawk to death and then maybe
accidentally also kills himself but we
are not sure by inducing a heart attack
homelander steps on termite which
if anybody missed he there he's gone so
no more penis holes
they have to be stopped
he's right he's raging our towns we need
to get him out of here yeah we got a
little satisfying squish with that so i
did love the existential crisis that
termite was suddenly in when he's like i
can't get big yeah again he was stuck
a burnt little yeah i was like oh he's
gonna be stuck as a little man forever
oh yeah yeah and it's like homeland or
went out it was either gonna be a
homelander or an owl that got it
honestly honestly got the better yeah
yeah the best of the two it would have
been funny to get scooped by an owl uh
all right so this episode homelander has
a total of one a train has a total of
one maybe two we don't know
self-inflicted maybe self-inflicted
has two soldier boy has 12 this episode
uh because he blew up so many people at
the party bringing our total to 16 this
episode pretty good pretty high up
that's a pretty good one yeah uh i like
that like every episode soulja boy is
gonna have at least ten
because he just gets he's like give me
that really racist sauce uh
uh so we have two more episodes left i
think two more they think there's eight
total yeah there's only two more there's
probably going to be another big
climactic fight i mean it was teased in
the first episode between butcher and
orlando when they're like we're gonna go
scorched earth again i mentioned again
here
i thought they were gonna be saving up
for the end you know i think we'll have
the fight again at some point
we already got a laser off i do i love
those different color lasers so we don't
get confused
i think now homelander's gonna go
immediately he's gonna know he's
probably gonna go talk to babe because
he's like i smell i know you and butcher
have been like doing something and it's
like but i knew you guys were
talking and now soulja boy's free yeah
two of them have v
what the hell happened i'm missing
something you're here tell me what
happened and i think they're gonna he's
gonna wash down all the b he's gonna
like put him down the drink oh he's
gonna get rid of all the temperatures do
you think that this i i was saying at
the beginning of the season i think they
need to
deal with homelander
in this season like yeah can we keep
going on with the show as having
homelander as the main threat or do you
think they're going to resolve that
either by killing him or in somehow
wiping his mind in a strange way
if they can't kill uh yeah i would like
if they can't kill him
i mean can you have this show without
butcher or homelanders they're our main
drivers i think you i think you could
have the sap parties i think you have to
show that butcher yeah
you need an equally bad person which is
why i think it's sold if he turns his
kid into that bad person yeah
it could be that yeah also i'm worried
about huey now i'm worried about my boy
huey i know god he's turned into such an
[ __ ] really yeah uh
what if he just like homelanders still
there but he only gets zapped partially
by the the uh
he loses like some of his powers or
maybe like half of all his powers or
like he no longer has vision or whatever
a homelander with a fear of mortality is
a new
a new homelander i think um what if he
loses his powers and he is like a normal
person oh god he genuinely was like that
was making me sick and now
i'm not saying i mean my fear is that
like he says that but it's really the
fully bad version oh no
it was better at being a psychopath and
we think homelanders picks
and then we get that like wink to the
camera boy yeah oh anthony's cheers to
you i'm amazing in person that that
mirror scene send it in for the emmy huh
yeah
so good he's such a good everyone's so
good at acting on this episode jen's and
uncles is terrible we also know homeland
during real life
we're not afraid to lay down some
threats
[Applause]
and that's it for our boys underground
this episode of the boys underground
thank you brandon barrick oh thank you
oh thank you miranda mastros you can
follow marina at marina masteros on
twitter you can follow barrick at
granite barrack
you can follow grin and barrack at grin
and barrett
you can follow me a little underscore
clemens and you can follow the new
rockstars at new rockstars on youtube
twitter instagram uh follow us on all
our social media platforms now follow us
on tumblr where i'm over there catching
up on some hot takes for miss marvel i'm
going a little crazy every time i say
i'm getting crazier and i tone it down
she finds a new oh i don't know
i post things but i'm not like too crazy
but i'm trying to talk to you guys i
just need to get everyone in a meeting
to ex to give out your questions so keep
asking questions on tumblr i'll get to
them join us on discord as long as
you're 18 and above to get talks and
some exclusive
[ __ ]
i want all that bleeped out from drew
the editor
have a nice day have a hero-gasm day
i'll have a couple hair grasses of
yourself take that long dick put it over
your backpack
[Music]
you